si alan masques étaient nés dans les
années 30 il aurait probablement eu le
même destin que ces deux étudiants ils
ont eu un projet fou construire une
vraie fusée dans leur jardin après deux
explosions qui leur valent le surnom d'
escadrons de la mort les autorités leur
demande gentiment d'aller jouer ailleurs
pourtant ils se découragent pas gagne en
notoriété et pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est à eux qu'on me demandera
d'analyser les v2 allemande larmes
ultime des nazis un missile capable de
tenir près d'une tonne de charge
explosive avec une portée de plus de 300
km là où les anciens modèles portent dix
fois moins lourd 30 fois moins loin et
très impression plus de ça c'est comme
ça que les deux bonhommes créé la jpl
jet propulsion laboratory qui est
aujourd'hui le centre de recherche le
plus renommé de la nasa tous en partant
de leur jardin ça paraît fou mais
contrairement à une idée reçue il n'y a
pas besoin de milliers d'ingénieurs de
la nasa pour faire ça on va voir
aujourd'hui comment marche une fusée est
ce que vous allez devoir faire si vous
voulez aussi envoyer votre voiture dans
l'espace
évidemment ne reproduisez jamais ce
qu'on va vous dire c'est extrêmement
dangereux ah oui cette vidéo est en
partenariat avec cyberghost vpn j'en
reparle pendant la vidéo on a de grosses
réductions à vous offrir aller dans
l'espace grâce à une fusée à eau est ce
que c'est possible envoyer une fusée sur
orbite sur le papier c'est étonnamment
simple il faut atteindre la première
vitesse cosmique tout objet qui atteint
la vitesse de 7 9 km par seconde ne
retombe plus jamais sur terre sauf que
7,9 kilomètres par seconde c'est quand
même dix fois plus rapide qu'une balle
de fusil donc pour atteindre cette
vitesse il ya pas de 36 mille solutions
il faut qu'à un moment ça pète
et que ça pète très fort tous les
astronautes vous le dire on monte dans
une fusée c'est s'attacher à une bombe
de plusieurs tonnes dont on essaie de
dompter l'explosion tu pense sûrement
que tu n'as pas d'explosifs aussi
puissant chez toi pour reproduire une
telle détonation et bien détrompe toi le
carburant qu'on va utiliser sort
directement de ton robinet quand j'étais
jeune je me rappelle qu'à l'école on
avait construit une fusée à eau pompe la
bouteille monte en pression jusqu'à ce
que ça paraît n'être qu'un jouet mais
même les fusées dernier crée de la nasa
utilisent ce principe newton le mec t'es
pomme avait baptisé sa action-réaction
situent surtout skate et que tu jettes
ton sac derrière toi action ça va te
faire avancer réaction donc pour que tu
as plus cette école le but et d'expulser
vers le bas à un maximum de matière en
un minimum de temps
la nasa le fait avec des gaz brûlants et
nous baroux le faisait avec de l'eau
problème le record actuel d'une
propulsion à eau et 2 960 m c'est trois
fois plus que la tour eiffel mais dix
fois rouen aucun avion de ligne il
existe heureusement une manière beaucoup
plus efficace est ce que tu me crois si
je te dis qu'à partir d'un simple verre
d'eau tu peux produire un gaz dans
mènera là haut pas besoin de matériel
high-tech juste une pile les deux bouts
de métal que tu plonges dans un verre
rajouter un peu de sel pour que l'eau
puisse conduire l'électricité et attend
quelques secondes tu devrais voir des
bleus là apparaître sur les bouts de
métal magie non chimie tu vois cette
technique est celle h2o la molécule
d'eau les oreilles ce sont 2 h deux
atomes d'hydrogène et au centre au
l'atome d'oxygène quand le courant va
passer dans l'eau du verts eelv a
arraché les oreilles de la tête on
appelle ça le craquage de l'eau les
hydrogène vont être attirés par le pôle
moins de la pile alors que les oxygen
vont migrer vers le pôle plus on aura
donc l'hydrogène qui va s'accumuler d'un
côté et l'oxygène de l'autre comme ces
atomes n'aime pas être tout seul ils
vont prendre une forme plus stable en
s'associant par paires pour former des
bulles de gaz du dihydrogène h2 et du
dioxygène o2 séparément ces gaz sont peu
inflammables mais quand ils sont
mélangés il suffit d'une petite
étincelle
et boum une explosion assez puissant
pour faire décoller notre fusée mais
nous on vise l'espace quelle attitude ça
fait ça et bien la frontière de l'espace
officiel existe pas ça s'appelle la
ligne de karmann à 100 km d'altitude il
nous faut donc assez de carburant or
avec un pack d'eau tu peux produire
assez de gaz pour propulser une pomme
dans l'espace sauf que ça c'est dans un
monde parfait le problème c'est que si
on fait tout péter d'un coup on à 99% de
chances d'éclater la fusée en mille
morceaux il faut canaliser l'explosion
l'étaler dans le temps un peu ce que
fait la gazinière de ta cuisine en moins
violent problème ce type de gaz est
tellement instable qu'à la moindre
recherche of la moindre fuite
pour régler ça j'ai peut-être une
solution un combustible solide aller
dans l'espace grâce à une fusée au sucre
le principe des feux d'artifice et ça
tue en flammes un tube contenant de la
poudre à canon et
l'avantagé c'est que t'as pas besoin
d'un réservoir lourds et compliqués qui
doit supporter des tonnes de pression
c'est juste un morceau de carton aussi
peu de risques d'explosion car pour
atteindre la poudre duo de feu d'abord
brûler la poudre du bas comme une
cigarette vous vous en doutez un la nasa
n'utilise pas de la poudre de pétards et
son évolution le propergol solide comme
on en fabrique bah y'a plein de méthodes
originales à base de soucis sont deux
pattes ou encore de bonbons ours une
recette sort du lot pour sa puissance et
sa facilité les sugar roquettes des
fusées au sucre le sucre ça ne brûle pas
pour ça s'enflamme il manque quelque
chose tu as peut-être déjà entendu
parler du triangle du feu il dit qu'on
ne peut créer une combustion que si
trois éléments sont réunis à combustible
qui apportent les charges - un
concurrent qui apportent les charges
plus et une énergie d'activation
l'étincelle qui lance la réaction des
ingrédients ne sont donc jamais choisi
au hasard quant à cheminer le bois et le
combustible le comburant et l'air
ambiant et l'énergie d'activation c'est
l'allumette étouffe le feu il ne brûle
plus enlève le bois pareil il nous faut
donc compléter notre triangle du feu le
sucré est un excellent combustible
comburant qui fonctionne très bien avec
lui c'est le salpêtre on en trouve par
exemple dans les désherbants pour se
débarrasser des souches ou dans la
charcuterie mais attention on ne mélange
pas sucre et ça peut être n'importe
comment il faut donner à notre poudre
notre propergol la forme d'un cylindre
percée pour permettre au gaz de
s'évacuer vers le bas grâce au canal
pendant que la combustion brûle les
bords du tube ça tombe bien puisque
notre mélange contient du sucre en
chauffant on obtient un beau caramels
mous qu'on peut me donner à notre guise
quand il est encore tiède puis refroidir
et durcir avec la forme voulue contre là
on va pas se mentir chauffer une patte
de deux poudres à canon on sent que
c'est pas une bonne idée des youtuber
ont tenté et certains ont frôlé la
catastrophe
il reste un dernier détail à régler la
cuillère pour que ça ne soit pas une
vulgaire fusée de feu d'artifice on peut
optimiser la poudre de la combustion
grâce à un tube en forme de sablier
c'est une tuyère de l'aval du nom de
l'ingénieur qui a conçu cette forme
caractéristique censée tuyères on
perdrait trop d'énergie sous forme de
chaleur et de pression voilà notre engin
après un type de poudre une cuillère et
c'est parti pour l'espace ça paraît
presque trop simple mais c'est comme ça
que fonctionnent les deux groupes
booster de la navette spatiale bien sûr
la nasa n'utilise pas de sucre trop
lourd trop l'an passé précis leur
propergol ressemble plutôt à ça sauf
qu'on a un nouveau problème quand
presque toute la poudre à brûler la
réaction devient instable le propulseur
vibre et son poids devient une charge
inutile c'est pour ça qu'on s'en sépare
pour ravir les derniers kilomètres on a
besoin d'un autre type de moteur dont on
peut ajuster la poussée juste en ouvrant
et en fermant une valve c'est le moment
d'utiliser le mélange hydrogène oxygène
qu'on a fabriqué au début et justement
si vous passez votre temps en fusée vous
aurez besoin de cyberghost vpn un dpn
va-tout chiffrer tout sécurisé et
empêcher qu'on vous localise qu importe
où vous êtes vous pouvez avoir une
connexion du pays de votre choix vous
voulez devenir américain allez hop c'est
comme ça que vous faites sauter les
limites géographiques
ce n'est pas disponible dans votre pays
parfait en voyage ou pour accéder à des
sites web et catalogues net x accessible
cyberghost vpn pèse lourd dans le game
du vpn validé par la stricte 5 étoiles
sur treize pilotes et preuve de leur
sérieux aucun log conserver cyberghost
vpn ne peut pas savoir quel site celle
où vous consultez c'est pour ça qu'on
vous régale avec une grosse promo -84%
quatre mois gratuit cet appareil
protégés sur tous les supports c'est
moins cher que le prix d'une fusée
satisfait ou remboursé alors n'attendez
plus lien en descriptions le turbomoteur
est la partie la plus cauchemardesque
d'une fusée allez au boulot on injecte
oxygène et hydrogène dans une chambre de
combustion trois deux un allumage
belle flamme contrôlable facile non
ok bon on a sauté quelques étapes pour
éviter d'avoir entreposé un gaz hyper
instable et dangereux l'oxygène et
l'hydrogène sont au départ stocké sous
forme liquide dans des réservoirs
séparer il te faut donc une pompe pour
les amener jusqu'au moteur pour
l'hydrogène facile par contre pompe et
de l'oxygène liquide c'est une autre
paire de manches l'oxygène liquide c'est
froid genre vraiment très froid moins
180 degrés ce qui fait que tout ce qu'il
touche gel et devient cassant mais c'est
pas son seul défaut le fait que ça soit
un excellent carburant entraîne le fait
qu'il est très occident en gros ils
essayent de bouffer tout ce qu'ils
trouvent il va donc enflammer des choses
qui ne sont pas censés brûlé comme la
plupart des métaux les joints en
caoutchouc ou l'huile de moteur bref
tout ce qui constitue une pente normal
il faut donc utiliser des matériaux
composites et limiter le nombre de
pièces mobiles tu commence à apercevoir
le challenge est en plus une fois qu'on
a construit une pompe qui gérera liquide
froid comme la mort hyper corrosif sans
finir bouffée de l'intérieur on fait
quoi admire le légendaire moteur merlin
développé par spe 6 falcon 9 au 16 9
moteurs comme celui là ce qui nécessite
de les alimenter par presque trois
tonnes de carburant par seconde une fois
les moteurs allumés il prône vise une
force énorme plus de 800 tonnes de
poussée et heureusement c'est comme ça
qu'on les a conçus ça veut dire qu'il y
règne une pression énorme dans la
chambre de combustion comment on fait
pour injecter nos trois tonnes de
carburant dans un réacteur déjà plein à
craquer eh ben on prend une pompe très
très puissant je pense qu'à ce stade tu
as compris qu'il nous fallait construire
le super sayen imagine qu'une bête
pareil ça bouffe une énergie colossale
pour fonctionner et on la trouve où
cette énergie à ce stade de conception
de la fusée les ingénieurs devaient être
au bout de leur vie et carbure au café
depuis plusieurs mois parce que la
solution qu'ils ont proposée ci ni plus
ni moins qu' on n'a qu'à alimenter notre
pont par un autre moteur de fusée
je rigole pas ils n'ont rien trouvé de
mieux que de rajouter dans leurs
réacteurs un mini propulseur juste pour
faire fonctionner la giga pompe mais
pour faire démarrer ce second propulseur
il faut encore une autre pompe inception
des réacteurs un cauchemar qui tu t'en
doutes a rendu dingue des milliers
d'ingénieurs une solution qu'ils ont
trouvée c'est de lancer toutes les
pompes au démarrage grâce à des amorces
d'explosifs on continue la liste des
problèmes tu te souviens de la tuyère ce
bout de métal qui canalise la poussée le
problème c'est qu'un bout de métal ne
peut supporter l'apocalypse de feu de
plusieurs tonnes de propergol faut
trouver un moyen de refroidir tout ça
mais ça tombe bien on a justement de
l'oxygène glacée comme jamais à
disposition il suffit de détourner
quelques tuyaux pour les faire circuler
autour de la tuyère c'est le petit
serpentins que tu vois sans rouler ici
c'est ce genre de plomberie capable de
supporter tous les feux de l'enfer tout
en transportant le liquide le plus relou
possible sans bien sûr se dilate et avec
la chaleur ni risquer la moindre suite
avec tous ces éléments qu'on rajoute
petit à petit pour régler chaque
problème le moteur est au final
tellement complexe qu'il est impossible
de le tester en entier avant le jour j
et n'oublie pas que dans une fusée
chaque gramme compte on a donc
évidemment pas le luxe de mettre un
système d'évacuation pour les gars qui
sont dedans au cas où ça se passe très
mal pour monter dans cette fusée qui
essaye quand même très très fort de te
tuer on va donc falloir être sacrément
sûr de toi ou suicidaires à toi de juger
à quelle catégorie appartient le platt
east michael young qui a fabriqué sa
propre fusée artisanale pour décoller
avec il était bien décidé à prouver une
bonne fois pour toutes que la terre
était plate o le parachute de la fusée
s'est détachée par accident et il s'est
crashé en plein désert c'était un
amateur mais même avec les pros ça se
passe mal sur les millions de pièces
mobiles que tu as fusée comporte
absolument personne ne peut garantir que
tout soit parfaite c'est ce qu'a rappelé
au monde la navette spatiale challenger
en 1986 la pièce défaillante qui a causé
cette tragédie un joint une petite
rondelles en caoutchouc d'un demi
centimètre de diamètre qui a mal
supporté la nuit froide avant le
lancement encore on n'a fait que flore
et la surface on n'a pas parlé
d'aérodynamisme de stabilisation de
pilotage de caen décoller selon la
position du soleil et des planètes pour
utiliser la gravité de coman maintient
l'équipage envie de comment on choisit
la trajectoire ça pourrait faire un
épisode de alors dites nous si ça vous
intéresse un commentaire en attendant
abonnez-vous merci à tous de nous suivre
toujours plus nombreux allaient les amis
[Musique]